scp-035 a ketter class object is a
mysterious porcelain mask that changes
between comedy and tragedy with all
visual records altering to match its
appearance emitting a highly corrosive
liquid from its eyes and mouth it causes
decay in everything it touches anyone
nearby feels an irresistible urge to
wear the mask leading to their brain's
Annihilation and possession by
scp-035's Consciousness the possessed
host body decays rapidly but scp-035
remains in control even as the body
crumbles this Sinister object is highly
intelligent manipulative and sadistic
with an intimate understanding of the
human mind
scp-035 has been found to possess
telepathic abilities and is capable of
motivating inanimate humanoid shapes
including mannequins and statues its
containment cell is manifested alarming
phenomena such as corrosive blood
Whispering voices and apparitions
causing increasing challenges in its
containment